クン
ブーパマンカーヤミマンヴィディンヴァーナガルーパマンチッタミダンタペッヴァーヨーデータマーランパンニャーブーデーナージタンチャラクケーアニヴェーセノーシアー
クンブーパマンカーヤミマンヴィディンヴァーナガルーパマンチッタミダンタペッヴァーヨーデータマーランパンニャーブーデーナージタンチャラクケーアニヴェーセノーシアー
そんなに難しい芸ではございませんので
クンブーパマンっていうのは水瓶ということで
あのー ずいぶんあの もろい
あのー インドの水瓶っていうのは素焼きで
それ大きいんだからね
大きいものに水を入れちゃうと
ちょっとしたことで割れてしまうんです
だいたい決まりとして別にバレたってもいいんじゃないかっていう感じで
よく作る それ水瓶っていうのは簡単に壊れてしまう
だからまあインドの素焼きの水瓶を想像しないと
あのー あまり意味が通らないかもしれません
インドではね 今もこの
まああんまりないみたいですけどね
まあ旅行なんかに行ったら
この お茶売ってますね
駅とか その時もあのカップに入れてお茶くれますけど
飲んだらそのままカップを
あの投げ捨てて壊すんです
それもまあ素焼きで まあ作っているもので
で 手で潰しても潰れちゃいます
まあ一回しか使わないということでね
あまり硬く焼いてないんだから
ほんのちょっと軽く焼くだけですから
まあ簡単に土にまた戻るんです
まあそういう感じで まあ家に水を汲むとき使う家に水
水を溜まっておく 置いておく水が
まあそんな程度のものに作るんですよ
だから大きくなればなるほどちょっと危ないんですよ
ちょっとしたことで まあ壊れてしまうんです
自分の体っていうのはこのように簡単に壊れるものであると知ってほしいっていうのは
まあお釈迦様の考え方なんです
で これが世間 世間 世間の考え方とは全く正反対ですから
まあ少々理解難しいとは思います
で 世間ではあのー 決して体っていうのは
あのー 簡単に壊れるものだとは思わないんです
すごく大事なものとして扱ってるし
完璧な清らかなものとして体を見ているのが普通なんですね
そういうことですから
このちょっとだけでも風邪でも引くと
もうかなり大騒ぎになるんです
あってはならないことが起きたと
で これはおかしいと で
少々病気になっても これはもう大変なおかしいことが起きたというふうに
まあ世間が驚くんですよ
で もう大変な大騒ぎにするんです
なぜかというと この人間の知識では
体っていうのは まあそう簡単に病気になるものでも壊れるものではなく
あのー かなり頑丈な まあすごく強いものなんです
ですから まああらゆる学問やら科学やら哲学やら宗教やら
まあそういうどちらでも
いかに長生きするのか
いかにより力強くなれるのかとか
いかに肉体的に超能力も発揮できるのかとか
まあそういうことしか考えてないんですね
だから より美しく より力強く
まあ完全な健康で あのー徹底的に長生きしたいという
で 一日でも早く長生きしたいというふうな考え方で生きてるんです
だから 体っていうのは簡単に壊れるんだっていうのはね
これは決してこの認めるものではありません
だからこの意味は簡単かもしれませんだけど
理解するのは難しいんです
で ですから この他人のごとく理解すればいいんじゃないかなと思います
で 当時であのお釈迦様の時代の比丘たちは
まあやっぱり世間で考える考え方と違う考え方で心を見ようとしている
ですから この実際に自分の体が水瓶のようにほんのちょっとのことで壊れてしまうんじゃないかなということで
かなりあの ジリジリと具体的に観察するんです
心を見ようとしている
ですから この実際に自分の体があの水瓶のように
ほんのちょっとのことで壊れてしまうんじゃないかなということで
かなりあの ジリジリと具体的に観察するんです
で これがそう簡単なものではないんですけど
まあ結構不安にはなります
怯えたりはします だってすぐ今
今でもこの体が壊れて死ぬかもしれませんと
これを本気で真面目に思っちゃうと結構不安になるでしょうね
だから普通の心育て方っていうのは死ぬわけないんだと
頑張れと 頑張りなさいというふうな
まあ普通 ね 我々はそういうことで心を安心させておくんです
そういうふうにこのまあ大丈夫だ
大丈夫だと 何の心配することもない
人は死ぬものじゃない
なんとか追い込んだというふうな考え方で
まあ心は安定している
そこで一人の人だけ大丈夫じゃないんだと
これはとても危ないんだと
おっかないんだと ちょっとしたことで死ぬかもしれませんと
いうふうに ちょっと異常な考え方を持つんですね
そういう異常な考え方を持つと
まあかなり不安になる
死は普通の人と違ってすごく怖く感じるようになるんです
だから まあ本当のところは
まあ死っていうのは まあ我々の心の中ではないんですね
頭の中で 死ぬという言葉さえも
まあ意味もわからないんで
死ぬという言葉の意味も
で 意味わかってるのかというとわかってないと思いますけど
大体まあ死ぬという場合は
私は死なんだけどね そこら辺にいるね
かわいそうな犬畜生は死ぬかもしれませんという
考え方ですね 頭にあるのは
だから自分の死っていうのは一度も考えたことはないんだから
その意味もわからないんですね
死はどういうものかと
そこでこのあえて自分の死を観察する
もう体っていうのは水瓶だと
思ったりすると その人にはやっぱり具体的に情報が入り込むんですよ
どういう情報かというと
やっぱりすーっと体が壊れていくんじゃないかなと
という ただ呼吸したっても
まあ考え方は 2つありますよ
例えば中国から伝わってくる古い伝統的な考え方では
これは宇宙の偉大なるエネルギーで永遠なんですね
だから気とかなんとか言葉がありまして
気功とかね それでも体は永遠に保たれますと
で エネルギーはもうずっと体で永久的にある
宇宙と一緒になればもう大丈夫やというね
考え方 それで私なんかスローモーションっていうことをやってくださいと言っちゃうと
もうほとんどやらない
逆らう なんてバカなことですかっていう
しかし 気功でスローモーションでやっている場合は
ずいぶん元気で もうやらない人っていうのはいないんですね
なぜかというと そこで気功の気功師の話を聞くと
永遠に死なないんですよ
で 心を整えることによって体は永久的に保たれると
この間  NHK の気功のプログラム見ましたけど
心を落ち着いてもらって
それで体を永遠に保つという考え方なんですね
だからそこは結構みんなに理解できる
体は永遠に保たれますということはね
で 体はそうじゃなくて
逆にすぐ壊れると言っちゃうと
これはなかなか理解できない
大変な難しいことになっているんです
そんなのはありえないと
体っていうのは本当に壊れるものかと
壊れるはずないという風に普通に思っちゃうんですね
ですから もうそういうところで
なんとなく世間の考え方とは結構
違った考え方 これがお釈迦様もよく知っていて
これはこの流れに逆らう道だとも言ってるんですね
で 流れに逆らうのは難しいでしょう
だから あのブッダが何考えているのかと理解したければ
やっぱりこの流れに逆らって思考を持っていかなくちゃいけないんですね
しかし この流れに逆らうということは
もう人間っていうのはしないんです
そんな大胆な過激的な人間っていうのはいないんです
みんなすごく行儀がよく
大人しく かなりもう道徳を重んじて生きてるんだから
みんな思っていることは思う
みんな言っていることは言う
みんな考えることは考えるというふうな生き方しているんです
ですから 証拠があってもなくても
みんな言うならばそれが正しいというふうな
みんなに逆らうんじゃないというね
で 生き方で自分の人格もそれで定めて育てているんです
そんなところで これでまるっきりもう大胆に過激的に 180度違うことを言うと
これはね 困ったもんですよ
インドでもね お釈迦様なんかもう世界を破壊する者やとと言ったバラモン人もいたんです
みんな言うことを言うのは当たり前
行儀よく正しいことなのに
この人はまるっきり反対のことを言って
もう世界を壊してるんではないかと
というふうな批判もありましたし
何人かのね インテリ系のバラモンたちがブッダに会ってそういうことを言ったことあります
ですから この体はこちらでは水瓶のように見ろというふうにあって
他のところではテーヌータマンカーヤミダンヴィリッワっていう
ゲームありまして 泡のようなものであると
で 体はただ泡の塊だと見てくださいと
というと これまた気持ち悪い考え方なんですね
で なぜかというと 体が泡のような泡の塊のようにと思っちゃうと
もう泡っていうのはもう持てないしね
すぐはじけてしまうし
まあせいぜい昔はなかったんだからね
今はスポンジみたいな
もう絶対壊れないっていうぐらいビニール製でできているスポンジ
スポンジぐらいでも言ってくれるとありがたいのにね
あのビニール製のスポンジのようなものである
引いても叩いても壊れませんよと
そんなにも泡のようなものやと言いたければ
スポンジのようにものであると言ってくれればありがたいんですけど
残念なことに当時はスポンジがなかったんですね
台所でこの皿とか洗ったりするスポンジっていうのは
あれはなかなか頑固なもので壊れないでしょう
雑巾なんかは簡単に使えなくなっちゃうでしょうね
スポンジはそうじゃないんです
もう結構頑固なんですね
だから私たちにとっては
体がそういうスポンジのようなもので
まあ壊れないもので 結構頑固であると言ってくれたら
大変幸せな気分にはなります
元気で生きていられることはできます
これが泡のように見なさいと
見ている間ですぐすぐはじけていくんだと
言うとすごい嫌な気持ちにはなります
で なんで嫌な気持ちになるのかって
やっぱり私たちは流れに沿って
全ての人間考える考え方に沿って
すごくおとなしく考えて生きてるんだから
そういうことだから なかなかこれのポイントはね
理解難しいとは思います
それで理解しようと思ったっても
結構おっかない思考ですよ
自分が今瞬間ででも自分の体がはじけてはじけてはじけていくんだと
と見てみることがかなり怖い感じが生まれてくるんです
かなり不安が生まれてくるんです
もういても立ってもいられないぐらい状態に精神状態が変わるんです
だから そんな怖いものを見たいという経験したいという勇気は人間にはないんです
ですから これはもう悟る人っていうのは
だから世の中でないというかね
勇気のある人以外はこれできないんです
とにかく流れに逆らう教えなんですね
そこでナガルーパマンチッタミダンタペットは自分の心についてはこのなんか何でしたっけ
なんか分からない感じ
ん？ 城壁  城？ 城郭 お城の壁っていうか
うん それ城郭のようにと日本語で書いています
それはパーリ語では街っていう風な書いてます
うーん 都会みたいな街です
だからどちらか自分に気に入る意味で取ってください
まあパーリ語の意味は街なんですね
日本語のはこれは城郭
多分あの城の壁で囲まれた街ってこと
中国のあの街みたいなのは
城塞都市っていう  あの街全体を
だからこれ城郭といえば街ですか
壁ですかね  なんていうか
壁っていうか  城郭は壁です
敵から守る塀っていうか
そういうものですね  城郭
これの場合 エリアっていうか
だから囲まれたエリアで
インドとか中国の街はそうなってます
日本はあんまりそういうのはないですけど
うーん だから うーん どんな意味で取るんでしょうかね
まあ城郭 えーと まあだから日本語で読む方々はそれは壁だと思う可能性もあるし
石原さんがおっしゃってるようなエリアって意味を取る場合もあるし
この辺は私はちょっとわからないんです
で とにかく街っていうのはパーリ語の意味なんです
街といえば 何かとといえば
まあ壁で囲まってるのは一応普通なんです
で 金持ちの連中は別にもうみんな集めて一か所で壁を作って
中に入り込んでるんです
時々 まあ今も金持ちはかなり大きい土地で家を作ってでっかい壁を作って
まあ今もね いろいろそういう建物はね
ある 今言えばだ 一人しか住んでないんですね
一つの家族だけ お城を作って
周りに壁を作って それに囲まって住んでいて
フランスやらイギリスやら
まあもう玄関から入ったらまだ車に乗っていかないと
ゲートから入ってもすぐ家ってわけじゃないんです
ずっとまだ車に乗っていかないと家に見つからないって
まあかなり土地があるんですね
その場合はやっぱり一人で住んでいるんです
まあ昔の場合はまあそんなに金持ちがいたかどうか分からへんんですけど
やっぱり金持ちの人は一か所で集めて
みんなまとめて まあ城壁を作って
その中に住んでると  [背景音楽]